-Our next guests are
the creators and stars
of the show "Three Busy Debras,"
which is streaming now
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-I'll hack into the mainframe
using top-of-the-line software.
And one fun fact about me is,
there's nothing fun about me.
-I'll be
the Debra on the ground,
and a fun fact about me is,
my favorite food is...
-I'm young for my grade
because I have a late birthday,
and I'm gonna distract
the security guard
doing what I do best.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the show
Sandy Honig, Mitra Jouhari,
and Alyssa Stonoha.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Well, I am so, so happy
to have all three of you here.
-We are so excited to be here.
-Please do not
take this personally.
Mitra, I'm a little extra happy
to have you here,
because Mitra --
this is a true story --
you are a former intern at
"Late Night With Seth Meyers."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are our first -- our first
returning intern,
and you probably don't
remember your last day.
Remember, you said to me,
like, "I'll be back!"
-Yeah, yeah, it was nasty,
but you deserved it.
You said a lot of really mean
stuff before I said that.
-I did but that's -- I try to
drive people to succeed.
Did you have a nice time
as an intern here?
-I had a really nice time.
-Good.
I mean, we can't believe.
We're so happy to have you back.
And it is so lovely to have
all of you guys together.
You met around the same time,
you were saying.
I guess, around seven times
ago -- seven years ago.
But this is -- these are
characters you created
the first time you did
an improv scene together?
-Yes, we were all, like --
We sort of
vaguely knew each other
through mutual friends,
and everyone kept telling us
we should hang out.
And so we got together and
we did an improv set.
And ahead of hanging out,
we were all, like,
just having a hard time
finding a time.
We were all just too busy.
So when we got onstage, we
ended up doing this improv set
where we accidentally
named all of ourselves Debra.
And the whole thing was just
about like, "We're so busy.
We couldn't possibly make time
for each other."
And then that was how we came up
with the idea for a show.
-And we haven't
had an idea since.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what the remarkable
thing about you guys is.
Your first idea was a good one
and your last one.
[ Laughter ]
You did have a premiere,
but you had COVID, Mitra,
so you could not go.
-Yes, on purpose.
-[ Laughing ] COVID on purpose.
You guys came up with
a very novel way
to make sure that Mitra was
with you at the premiere.
What did you come up with?
-You know, we thought
the only way that we
could honor her spirit
is to tape a picture of
her face onto a sex doll.
-Yeah.
-And toss her
around the party.
-You know, I thought it
would look a little slapdash,
but you obviously got
some real professionals,
because you can hardly tell.
[ Laughter ]
-And you know, it's hard
to tell in the photo,
but the sex doll actually does
have three tempting holes.
-Oh, wow.
If I find out
you have a hashtag ad...
[ Laughter ]
You guys also --
Here's your executive producer,
Amy Poehler.
-The way we got introduced
to working with her was,
we had been doing our play,
"Three Busy Debras,"
in a black-box theater.
And then we decided
we wanted to put on the show
again, but it was --
-No one would have us.
-No one would have us,
basically, 'cause
the show was disgusting.
And then --
-So, wait,
this is no black-box theater
would have you?
-Yeah, we couldn't find
a single place in New York.
-Well, there aren't a ton of
theaters here.
-We used to do this show
at this black-box theater
in Brooklyn
called The Annoyance,
and we made such a disgusting
mess every week.
We would boil hard-boiled eggs
and peel them onstage
at the beginning of the show.
It created quite a stink.
There was actually
a mystery smell in the theater,
and we were, like,
the number-one people
being like, "Ew,
this theater, like, stinks.
Like, why does it smell so bad?"
Until we received an e-mail
that it was, in fact, us,
and our props that had
rotting eggshells in them.
-And then we decided that we --
that you --
We wanted to perform
at Carnegie Hall as a joke.
We were like, "It'd be so funny
do this show at Carnegie Hall.
I wonder what that's like.
I wonder how hard that is."
And it turns out,
you just have to pay for it.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone who performs there
is just renting it.
So we did a Kickstarter
to rent it,
but the tiers
to get lights and tech
were a lot more expensive
than the basic package
of getting onstage.
-Yeah.
So, we did perform
an original two-act musical,
um, about the
three busy Debras,
to an audience
with the house lights up.
We could see
everyone's eyes and faces.
And five minutes
before the play started,
Amy e-mailed us,
wishing us good luck.
-Sandy, famously,
was checking e-mail
before the biggest night
of our lives.
-And I can't explain that one.
I don't know why, right before,
I was like, "Oh,
let me check my e-mail.
That's a great idea."
-And thank God you did.
-And thank God I did.
-You guys also have a lot of
original music in the show,
and you have an soundtrack
coming out.
That's really exciting.
When can we hear this?
-June 24th.
-Alright!
June 24th, the music of
"Three Busy Debras"!
You guys, thank you so much
for being here.
It's lovely to meet you both.
It's lovely to have you back.
Sandy Honig, Mitra Jouhari,
Alyssa Stonoha.
All episodes of
"Three Busy Debras"
are streaming on HBO Max.
And the show's
original soundtrack
will be available to stream.
We'll be right back.